il y a aussi l'affaire Lana on va
revenir sur cette affaire parce qu'il y
a des nouveaux éléments et Lana on va
rappeler l'histoire puisquon l'a
retrouvé il y a quelques jours he Lana
vous P rappeler pour nos téléspectateurs
et il y a de nouveaux éléments qui sont
tombés alors Loana c'est à Sedan c'était
la semaine dernière mardi après-midi
Loana qui a 10 ans et demi quitte son
collège qui est à une dizaine de
kilomètres de Sedan elle prend un bus et
elle est déposée
euh à à l'arrêt de bus le plus proche de
chez elle qui est l'arrêt turen glden et
ensuite elle n'arrivera jamais chez
elles les parents s'inquiètent assez
rapidement vont au commissariat de
police de Sedan signalent la disparition
de leur filles les policiers prennent
l'affaire très au sérieux tout de suite
compte tenu de l'âge et et de de tous
ces éléments euh et ils vont dans la
soirée faire ce qu'on appelle un avis de
un avis à témoin un avis de recherche
oui et le lendemain une une habitante du
du quartier du côté de la rue
Saint-Michel à San qui est dans le
centre un peu historique de Sedan
appelle la police en disant qu'elle a vu
cette gamine parce que dans la vie de
recherche il y avait une description
physique extrêmement précise de cette de
cette petite
fille manteau gris manteau noir veste
rose basket et cetera et donc cette
femme est persuadée d'avoir avir vu
l'ANA en train de discuter avec un
monsieur qui habite au 21 rue
Saint-Michel donc évidemment les
policiers se précipite à cette adresse
là on tombe sur le la photo vous avez
derrière vous le le bar sedanis qui est
un bar qui est désaffecté qui est fermé
avec juste une habitation au-dessus les
policiers tapent à la porte le locataire
ouvre la porte il s'appelle
Jean-Baptiste men il a 57 ans et et là
bah il avait l'air de s'attendre un
petit peu à la visite de la police et
lorsque les policiers fouillent un petit
peu à la fois dans le bar et surtout
dans dans son appartement il découvre
des pièces maculées de sang il y a du
sang dans le bar il y a du sang dans son
appartement et il y a des traces de sang
qui descendent l'escalier qui les
emmènent vers la cave
et là ils arrivent à la cave et ils
découvrent le corps de cette malheureuse
gamine enroulée dans un dans un drap et
malheureusement décédé alors euh il y a
eu des nouveaux éléments et on sait
qument c'est passé parce que il y avait
il y a il y a le suspect qui a avoué le
viol he mais qui a nié le meurre oui
alors l'autopsie révèle qu'elle a été
violée et également
tué avec des coups il y a pas il y a pas
eu de de coup de de revolver ou de ou de
couteau elle a été tuée uniquement à
main nu donc c'est une horreur absolue
pu qu'on sait maintenant ce qui s'est
passé hein oui c'est ça alors elle elle
elle connaissait ce son son tueur elle
connaissait Jean-Baptiste
men qui est un type issu du du du voyage
de la communauté des gens du voyage il
est divorcé il est au chômage il a six
enfants je crois et il est toujours un
peu sur une poche il est toujours entre
de vin et il était plutôt copain avec le
papa de Loana ils échangeaient ils
étaient pêcheurs tous les deux et donc
ils échangeaient du poisson il se
refilait du poisson et du coup cette
gamine euh connaissait son son bourreau
euh depuis depuis un certain temps et
lorsque le témoin qui signale la
disparition enfin qui signale l'effet à
la police euh
elle les voit en train de discuter c'est
ça il l'attrape pas pour l'emmener de
force il discute et je crois savoir
enfin je sais même que il lui aurait
proposé de boire un verre d'eau donc il
a fait monter chez lui au prétexte
fallacieux de lui offrir un verre d'eau
parce qu'au départ il disait qu'il a été
tombé dans les escaliers alors quand il
est en garde- à vue en audition il il il
reconnaît rien au début mais ça c'est
classique précette question il finit par
reconnaître surtout quand on a les
résultats de l'autopsie et que cette
gamine a évidemment été violée les
policiers lui lui opposent cette cette
analyse médicale et il finit par
reconnaître le viol donc il reconnaît
qu'il a violé euh la petite Lana en
revanche
il il ne veut pas reconnaître le meurtre
il dit que c'est un accident quielle est
tomberé dans l'escalier et maintenant on
non c'est un peu plus comme vous nous
l'avez dit donc c'est sans armes c'est
vraiment à main nuit c'est encore c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'estastr VI
juste on a oublié de dire qu'il était
présumé innocent on est obligé bien s il
est présumé innocent bien sûr oui bien
sûr
c'est mais la lo la loi dit qu'il est
prés inocnu présumé le VI d'un gamine de
ans même si tu reconnais les fait non
mais c'est c'est c'est
unecasse rentre pas là-dedans on va on
va s'énerver pour rien c'est la loi
ouais ouais mais c'est la loi non mais
laisse tomber c'est des lois qui datent
a longtemps le procès il est av innocent
c'est
ça incroyable oui ver alors il est mis
en examen pour pour meurtre et vu ce
qu'il a fait là si je puis dire si je
puis dire la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il
risque cette fameuse peine de perpétuité
incompressible parce qu'il rentre dans
les critères ça il pourrait être
condamné si ça va bout à cette peine qui
fait que si jamais son cas étudié un
jour ce serait au bout de 30 ans et
encore étudié par trois juges de manière
collégiale donc peut-être que s'il est
condamné il ne sortira jamais de prison
voilà puisque aucun condamné à cette
peine n'est jamais sorti de prison
fournirit qui avait été condamné à ça il
y en a h en France est mort en prison
voilà et même au-udelà des 30 ans il
peut très bien rester en
prison oui c'est minimum 30 ans
alors donc là aujourd'hui vous nous
aviez dit qu'il la quantité de sang
retrouvé une correspondit pas qu'un seul
corps c'est ce que nous disent les
téléspectateurs est-ce qu'on en sait un
peu plus làdus alors oui j'ai essayé de
me renseigner là-dessus a
priori les fonctionnaires de police qui
ont fait les constatations étaient pas
rôés en tout cas pas peut-être habitué à
avir une telle scène et on peut le
comprendre et je pense qu'ils ont un peu
exagéré parce que un corps humain
contient 5 L de sang et lorsque le corps
se vide de son sang ça fait vraiment une
une une quantité de sang absolument
incroyable mais a priori c'est c'est pas
il y a pas d'autres affaires il vérifie
évidemment mais ouais sur laffire Lina
juste il y a une personne qui me dit
qu'il a il y a des des images d'une
caméra qui a été qui ont été effacé par
un propriétaire du village où elle a
disparu est-ce que vous avez alors oui
c'est c'est pas qu'elles ont été Lina
voilà oui c'est pas qu'elles ont été
effacées ces images c'est qu'il y avait
pas suffisamment de comment dirais-je de
de capacité
dans le disque dur de mémoire et du coup
pour que ça puisse continuer à
fonctionner ça efface automatiquement
des des images déjà enregistrées qui
aurait pu être alors je voudrais
maintenant qu'on parle à 21h vraiment de
cette affaire ce gros dossier on va
revenir sur une image terrible d'un home
jacking à Paris on va voir si on vous
passe l'image dans un instant parce que
on attend justement vraiment voilà
d'être sûr parce que c'est une image
effroyable des hommes se sont fait
passer pour des livreurs pour accéder à
un appartement ils ont violemment
agressé une femme qui se trouve à
l'intérieur de cet appartement
étranglement coup ils se sont mis à
plusieurs sur elle les caméras de
surveillance ont filmé la scène vous
allez voir ces images qui font froid
dans le dos et euh on a également des
images he voilà de de de ces policiers
euh d'autres individus donc qui auraient
été interpellés par la police qui
faisaiit euh des mêmes même comambri
similaire regardez juste les images euh
des policiers qui les interpellent et
vous allez nous en dire plus juste après
parce que c'est pas la même affire
exactement c'est pas la même affaire du
tout puisque les autres sont encore en
liberté plusieurs affaires ou